I don't believe in US democracy
and I for sure don't believe that
changing the individual in charge
will change the system as a whole
or the foreign policy that the US has
maintained towards Palestine
and with that being said
I urge every single one
of you who is American
who has the right to vote in this country
to vote uncommitted in the primaries
look up when your primary is in your state
I know that Massachusetts
has its primary tomorrow
Tuesday March 5th
If all that it does is send a
message to the Democrats
that Americans are not
buying their crap anymore
then so be it
you don't lose anything
by going to the primary tomorrow (in MA)
and circling uncommitted
where it says presidential candidate
because apparently
the Democratic Party is extremely dense and
thinks that the reason why
people in Michigan voted uncommitted is
because it was just like all the Arabs
this is your chance to send
the Democratic Party a message
that the Palestinian cause has now been internationalized
that there is international solidarity
with the Palestinian cause
across races
across class
and across all ethnic backgrounds
people are coming out in droves
in support of the Palestinian people